قال مفوض والسياسات الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان افعال الاتحاد في مواجهه حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا فاجات الكثيرين من حيث
شراء السلاح لاوكرانيا وتقليل الاعتماد
على النفط الروسي جاء ذلك خلال مشاركه
بمنتدى
والدفاع ببروكسيل
انا واكشن
لقد فاجا تفعلنا الكثيرين لم نسمح لروسيا
ان تقسمنا بل على العكس من ذلك كنا وما
زلنا متحدين اكثر من اي وقت مضى لقد
اعتمدنا 10 حزم من العقوبات لممارسه اقصى
قدر من الضغط الجماعي على روسيا لقد قللنا
اعتمادا على النفط والغاز الروسيين في
غضون اشهر كما دعمنا اوكرانيا بالمعدات
العسكريه ومن خلال تمويل توريد الاسلحه
الى بلد في حاله حرب باستخدام موارد
ميزانيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
الى بروكسل مع مراسل الجزيره عبد الله
الشامي عبد الله مرحبا بك معنا اذا في
تصريحات بورين في اهميتها وايضا اهميه هذا
المنتدى
نعم محمد هذا المنتدى الذي يعقد في نسخته
الاولى هذا العام يريد الاتحاد الاوروبي
منه ان يكون مميزا دون غيره من المنتديات
التي تعقد هنا في اوروبا والتي يكون من
ابرزها منتدى اوسلو الامن وكذلك منتدى
ميونخ للامن هذا المنتدى يضم وزراء دفاع
الاتحاد الاوروبي بالاضافه الى وزراء دفاع
من خارج الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك مشاركه
لكندا والولايات المتحده بالاضافه الى
ثلاث وزراء لكل من الصومال والنيجر وغانا
يقول المفاوض سيده الخارجيه انه سيكون
اساسا لشراكه مستقبليه بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبين الحلفاء الذين وصفهم بمن
يتشاركون نفس القيم والمبادئ وهي كما
اسماها عالم متعدد الاقطاب وعالم يؤمن
بالعدوى القانون لانه كما قال في كلمه
الافتتاحيه اليوم هناك سعي من قبل موسكو
وبجين وغيرها من الدول التي اسماها بالدول
السلطويه الى فرض عالم متغير عما يسود
عليه الحال منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
قال ان الحرب في اوكرانيا ستغير كثيرا من
قواعد اللعبه حول العالم بسبب الوضع الذي
افرزته من حيث استخدام روسيا للطاقه
والغذاء كاسلحه في مواجهه هذه العقوبات
الاوروبيه المفروضه بالاضافه ايضا الى
الشركات المستقبليه سيكون هناك ميثاق
تاسيسي لهذا المنتدى يتم الاعلان عنه مع
نهايه هذا اليوم ينتظر ان يلقى بوريل كلمه
خلال دقائق من الان هي وهي ستكون كلمه
ختاميه للجلسه النقاشيه الاولى بالطبع
هناك جلسات اخرى على هامش هذا المنتدى
سيكون هناك الحديث الاكبر منها حول
البوصله الاستراتيجيه للاتحاد التي تسعى
الى تكوين هذه الشراكات مع دول من الجنوب
بالتحديد افريقيا والشرق الاوسط التي قال
عنهما بوريل ان اطرافا كثيره من هذه
المناطق تواصلت مع الاتحاد الاوروبي بعد
الحرب في محاوله لتوثيق الصله والاواصر ما
بينهما بوريقا لان الحرب في اوكرانيا
تستطيع ان تهزم الاتحاد الاوروبي بالعكس
بوتين كان يريد ان يرى اوروبا مقسمه
وضعيفه كما قال لكنه في المقابل راى
اوروبا اكثر قوه واتحادا وزادت ربما من
اتحادها في مواجهه هذا الامر وقامت بخطوات
غير مسبوقه من ابرزها شراء سلاح
لاوكرانيا هذا المنتدى بالطبع ياتي بعد
اجتماع الامس لوزراء الخارجيه والدفاع
الاوروبي الذي تم فيه التوافق على شراء
ذخيره بمبلغ ملياري يورو لصالح اوكرانيا
سيتم ايصال الدفعات الاولى منها مع نهايه
هذا الشهر ثم سيكون هناك خط انتاج منفصل
لصالح اوكرانيا لانتاج الذخيره والعتاد
الذي تحتاجه لكن بالطبع كما انهى بوريل
كلمته هذا الصباح وغيره من الوزراء
المشاركين العالم ان يكون كما كان بعد هذه
الحرب وهناك اتجاه ربما لعالم ستكون فيه
التنافسيه اكثر بكثير ولن يكون الامر
خاضعا للنقاش وانما للمواجهات اكثر والله
الاشياء من بروكسل شكرا لذلك